Hello everybody, I'm sorry, I'm sorry for the delay, but it didn't matter because itch.io is down.
Apparently I was on the Reddit, it's been down for like two hours already.
So even if I started on time, we still would have pivoted because itchio, I don't know, maybe someone's DDoS.
Someone was mad about not winning a different game jam or something.
So they decided DDoS, DDoS itchio.
I mean if you pissed off a I feel like when you if you piss off a developer a game dev Um, I think like I think that's that seems like something that could happen like
I don't know they got the tool.
Yeah, they got the tools right in front of them Or maybe the credit card or maybe the credit card thing it could be that it could be either Um, it could be either a credit card thing or Or, um, or, or, like, someone just got mad at Ichio about something and just decide.
Or, I mean, it could be that, too.
They got mad about Ichio removing some games.
And then they decided DDoS Ichio because of, because of a credit card, the credit card issue.
Um, um, so yeah, uh, it's, uh, it's down right now.
Um, or, and it's, like, really slow.
So I can load up.
I did load up.
i did load up like oh my rewinds on yeah sorry my my uh my manager made my waiting room guys know this whenever my my staff makes my winning room um uh i've uh they forget to turn off dvr so um i'm so used to just going live because when i make the waiting room i already i turn off the dv also rewinds off now when i make the waiting room i um always i automatically turn off dvr because It's just like,
um, reflex at that point.
It's just like, uh, blah, blah, what's the word?
It's just my, like, oh, fuck, what's the word?
It's just routine at that point.
So, uh, so, yeah, it's a habit.
Yeah, it's sick muscle memory.
Yeah, that's the word.
It's muscle memory, second nature for me now to turn off DVR.
But obviously, uh, my sad doesn't make my weight even very often.
it's only when I'm like super tired or um I'm like already in bed and I don't like I would be like I'm gonna I'm gonna like uh rest in bed for a little bit I'm gonna lie down for a little bit and uh I'll get up later because I'm like really I'm like a bit eepy and then I get I get on my bed and I'm like wait I'm very eepy I don't really want to get up I'm like extra eepy time um the bed has taken another victim um andy think it was super chat thank you thank you man recommend making this a shame dad stream think it was super chat thing you think oh i was gonna shame him regardless of whether or not itchio was down um anyway someone was asking why do i turn rewind off um there's a couple of reasons so uh one reason why i turn um uh i turn rewind off um is because uh it was was a uh a rule back then where we had to turn it off um because like um if you know if there was any like anything happening on the stream um we can private the stream instantly so people usually you know it can't if
something happens people can't rewind back to whatever happens on the stream so it was like a way to mitigate like any um anything that any oh my gosh sorry my brain's tired any little oopsies that might happen on stream like whether it's like something where you know um my gosh sorry my brain is like super slow because it's in the morning yeah it's like risk reduction yeah it's like a safe guide really like you know like if accidentally it doxed or uh something happens on stream where you know um you're playing a game and some people decide to be some gamers or anything and it's harder so you know we have to like private the stream snip it out and then unprivated or never never take like or keep it private forever so it just helps it's more like a safeguard thing where um where we we don't have the rewind on so so people can't just rewind it back to it and clip it.
So it prevents clipping for anything like controversial that might happen on stream, like any risk that happens on stream.
So people can't just rewind and clip it.
Another reason why I like to put Rewind on, this is my, it's a per, for me now, since I'm not corporal, for me, it's also personal reasons.
Because,
I prefer having rewind off so that people are watching what's going on now.
And when people are like chatting, chatting, they're all seeing what's happening now on stream versus like what's going on like, you know, an hour ago, they're watching a rewind.
And more so it gives off the live feeling of the stream.
And that's for me, that's my personally, it's like an in the moment thing.
So that's my own personal.
reasons but like you know there is that first reason which is like um which is like more so like a must a habit that i kept from from the before times um aphelion thank you for the magenta soup but thank you thank you donkey jam or not i'm glad to start my birthday with a donkey shame hope you and the dragons are having a good one thank you thank you for the magenta soup but thank you thank you i really appreciate it happy birthday to you happy birthday to you happy birthday to aphelion.
Happy birthday to you.
Yeah.
Happy birthday.
But yeah.
Um, what is that?
Where was that?
Where was I?
Where was my train?
Oh yeah.
For those who are running wide, my brain is really slow today.
And uh, I'm like lagging a little where I'm like, I can't, I can't figure out words right now.
I'm stumbling.
It's because that has been a piece of lately the last couple of days um um basically I think like the for the last week and a half he has gone to this new routine and I might need help I might need some ideas on how to stop him
so basically um what he does he he just started this new routine and I don't know what to do to stop him is that he wakes me up at 6.30 a.m.
for his food for lunch breakfast and then I go back to sleep and then usually after that he's fine like he'll wake up whenever I wake up but now for the last week and a half he has been waking me up at 6.30 a.m.
and then also at
and he would just i let him on my bed and so he would just like jump down from the bed and then just start like not jump down start use the stairs you use the stairs stand in front of my door and just be like and just like just keep barking at me and then um obviously um i'd be like no and then he would get back on my bed um lick me like lick my face and whatever because you're like i know you're still i know you're awake come on get up get up get up get up get up i wake And I'd be like,
no.
And then I just like, I would just like hold up my blanket.
And then he'll just crawl under my blanket and be like, okay, I just, I can rest a little longer.
And then I think like 15 minutes, 15 to 20 minutes will pass.
And then he'll be like, hey, wake up, wake up, wake up, wake up, wake up, wake up.
And he'll like, he'll like walk down the stairs, sit in like, stand in front of my door again.
Be like, wake up, wake up, wake up, wake up, wake up, wake up, wake up, wake up, wake up, wake up.
my god and he he has been doing that for the last week and a half and i i i even like when i fed him okay um i have like i i i have like tried to like i brought out the bark collar uh i don't turn it on for those who are wondering i don't turn on my bark collar it's just like more so like ptsd for him to kick in but he's like i think he has outgrown the ptsd because um i fed him and i put the collar on him just to be like just to be like okay maybe he won't wake me up a second time and he'll just sleep and he called my bluff because exactly 11 a.m he'd be like hey wake up wake up wake up wake up wake up wake up wake up hey hey wake up wake up wake up wake up wake i'm just
So, so, so I'm like, so I've been having like really bad sleep lately just because he, he won't stop.
He, he, he doesn't stop.
There's no, there's no snooze button on dog.
I don't know what to do.
It's like he wants me to start sleeping earlier.
Like, who kind of freak is he?
I can't believe this fucking dog is trying to make me healthier or something.
Oh my god.
Next scene, thank you for this super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, it's always seemed weird to me that you can chat if you weren't watching the live feed.
I get you.
Thank you.
Bro, thank you for the super chat.
Hi, it was Mother and Mother and my brother's birthday earlier this week.
Could they get a happy birthday?
Of course, Broku.
Happy birthday to you.
Oh, wait.
No, to your mom and brother.
Happy birthday to your mom and brother.
Happy birthday to them.
Yay!
Happy birthday!
Um, yeah, no, it feels like he's training me right now, and I hate it.
I hate it so much.
Yeah.
Um, I'm just like, that's why the...
like my sleep I just been like having really bad sleep lately just because um just because of him like waking me up in like back to back and now I'll try to go back to sleep too and he'll still wake me up so like if I if he wakes up at 10 30 I'll like you know I'll be like no and that's like my snooze button for him and um and then he'll uh and then he'll like wake me up like like on like he'll keep waking me up every like 10 to 15 minutes or like 10 15 minutes And so it's like,
it's been such a, it's been a struggle.
Lately, the last week and a half, I don't know what to do.
It's either, it's like, I don't know.
I don't know what to do.
I mean, I could just sleep earlier, but I don't know.
I mean, I could, I know, like, I could just sleep, but I don't know, guys.
It feels like I'm, I have no options, guys.
I feel like there's nothing I could do, guys.
Just absolutely nothing.
Georgia's thank you for the super chat thank you thank you Namo Namo Amitabu Hey Doki hope things get better for you and dad Also today's my birthday can you sing a song for me in Cantonese if you feel comfortable Don't just hi thank you for the super chat Georgia's thank you thank you I don't remember I was singing Cantonese,
um, are not singing in Mandarin for some fucking reason.
I think I just never had, I had the birthday song sang to me in Cantonese before.
I've only had it sang to me in Mandarin.
Just because like, um, because, uh, majority of my extended family speaks, uh, Mandarin.
So whenever it was my birthday, when I used to live in Asia, it was my they'll all sing it in Mandarin instead of Cantonese.
So, my mom's side speaks Cantonese, but when I celebrate my birthday with my mom's side, they'll sing it in English.
And then when I celebrate it with my dad's side, they'll sing it in Mandarin.
So I've never actually heard the Cantonese version of Happy Birthday.
I've only heard Mandarin and English.
So I said,
Happy birthday.
I don't know if I'm actually saying it correctly because I just said one line over and over.
Na Na Na, thank you, thank you, thank you.
After one and a half years of applying to jobs, I finally landed a job!
I'm very happy that I can still be able to continue to support your channel.
Thank you.
Oh, sorry.
I'm sorry.
I've been saying happy birthday, like the last 10 minutes.
But congratulations.
I'm so proud of you.
I'm glad you finally got your job.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Jakarta.
The super chat.
Thank you.
Between dad barking and NSL.
some last name and him barking and word really does sound like he's trying to train to be healthy thank you super chat thank you thank you i hate it dog's supposed to reflect the owner how could you betray me like this i don't even let you pay rent you do this to me how could you but yeah that's why like my brain in the morning has been very slow lately um like i'm having trouble finding words just like because I haven't had been having the best to sleep.
Like, literally, like, I woke up at, like, 12 p.m.
today, and then I messaged my manager, and I was, like, can you push my waiting room, like, 30 minutes?
I'm so tired.
And then my manager was like, yeah, I could do that.
I'm just like, and I just laid in bed, and I was like, I looked at dad, and I was like, how could you?
How?
raised you since you were a baby.
How could you do this to me?
I put a roof over our heads.
I give you wet food.
What more do you want from me?
But for some, for those who are like, oh, get him an auto feeder.
He has to eat wet food.
Well, he doesn't have to, but it's better for his kidneys.
So that's why he doesn't have an auto-feeder because I don't think I can auto-feed wet food.
I didn't ask the vet.
I was like, is it possible to like change his diet to dry food again?
And they're like, well, it's not ideal, but I guess you could.
But it's not ideal.
I was like, oh, can I get like recommendations on like what dry food I could use then?
And then they never, they always somehow forget to give me the recommendation.
Because I remember, I asked twice.
And then they're like, what's ideal?
But yeah, I can give you a recommendation.
And then they just never, it just never, they just never gave it to me.
I think it just never existed.
I guess there's no recommendation.
He's just going to be like a spoiled pieces of shit for the rest of his life.
Nana, thank you for the rate.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
I hope you had a good stream.
But yeah, for those who are wondering why we're just here chatting, I don't know what to do today.
I honestly don't know what to do.
Manny, thank you for the gift and chips.
Thank you, thank you.
So I'm just, I haven't really had a chatting stream.
I think this is why my brain is really slow too.
They're like, they sell auto-wet food.
Oh my God.
I feel like that's, okay, Robert, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That sounds disgusting.
Like, wouldn't the food like rot or wait, auto-wet food feeding?
I feel like, I feel like the food would just like rot, right?
Like, and the cleanup too sounds fucking terrible.
I feel like.
They have, we'll have to refrigerate, what's the point of an auto food feeder?
If I have to refrigerate it, then it's not automatic.
I have to put it in the fridge and take it out of the fridge.
Oh, it itself is, okay, I was going to say, do I put the entire thing?
Okay, so it's like a mini fridge.
Oh, I see.
It's like, oh, I like how they're mostly, it's for cats.
It's mostly for cats.
More sense.
I was like, there's no way.
Like, do I like, do I have to put the thing in the fridge?
Like, okay, so I like how it's mostly for cats, too.
Oh, it's like a, oh my gosh, it's so disgusting.
Oh my gosh, I have to clean it, though.
Looks a little disgusting.
Not gonna.
Yeah, it looks, it looks incredibly cat-coded.
For long-lasting cooling semiconductor.
Three mode settings.
Oh my gosh, it would be pretty ideal, though.
not gonna lie this would solve a lot of my problems um but like cleaning it i mean it was just i just had to clean clean it like when it's done i guess um i'm looking through it i mean it could help i don't have to worry about him waking me up at 6 30 in the morning anymore because i should sleep through uh krish thank you for the five give the ships thank you thank you rice thank you for give the chip thank you thank you i'm looking at i think oh yeah so i think also like i've been selling my words a lot so i haven't done a lot of like chatting pure chatting streams in a long long time and so i think my brain has just like uh deteriorated like the i'm i'm deteriorated a little bit because i haven't like actually chatted chat in a while since i've been so busy so i guess i just have to like warm up again at the regain my chatting skills yeah it has been a while it
no like the thing is he requires other things is i can't do dry food for him because uh he he has to eat wet food because he has a special kidney diet uh for or actual brain rot maybe i just watched too many youtube shorts guys the brain rot is settling in i think i watched i think I've been watching too many YouTube shorts.
But yeah, he has a special diet that he needs to follow for his kidneys.
Like, the food is actually called, like, special.
It's, like, a kidney diet.
So, and that's why I can't...
That's why I've been asking...
I asked the vet, like, twice.
Like, oh, do you have recommendations?
And he has never given to me.
Like, every time, every time.
And because I don't want to get him the wrong food.
Just in case, you know, I don't want to, like, you know, I don't want him to...
I don't want to, like, fuck up his kidneys.
He's middle-aged now.
Like, anything can happen.
I could.
Alright, the best taste.
Okay, how long...
How long do they last, though?
Wet food...
Uh...
Okay.
Cooked meat.
Okay, with our...
Can keep canned food fresh.
Oh, for one to...
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Okay.
So, I can literally stock it up for...
Oh, wait, that's great.
I can stock up, like, four days worth...
of uh four days worth of canned food wait that's great okay i'm gonna order okay guys i'm gonna order this i need this like i'm so i need this this will fix my sleep schedule i that's actually really ideal for me all right oh my god that's so tall this why is this so fucking tall all right uh three days true barren freshness three males semi-conductor quick chills gravy wet okay this is a cat feeder but that's basically a fucking cat at this point um all right i'm reading this chill pull out his room for three servings of wet food so you have extra room for flexibility in your let thank fucking god i can finally sleep uh
all right wet food on a mat oh my god how the fuck does this okay it's 179 but i'm just prevent naughty pets from sneaking in extra snacks with the pot okay uh check the feeding time okay auto repeat feeding meal plans can extend to four hours easy manual feeding i don't know is this is this okay just like is this okay with two okay no this one's with an ice pack i need a bridge I mean I I don't know if this is the one I should buy I'm like reading through it I'm so confused I'm just I'm just so confused it's like what the fuck am I what the fuck am I reading um okay I'm just okay the only thing I'm concerned about is is he too short for this do you guys too,
do you think he's, do you think this is too tall?
I don't know.
I don't know if this is too tall for him.
Okay.
Guys, do you think, do you think this feeder is too tall?
Because I can't tell.
I,
because like, dad is a short king and I, I can't tell.
if this is considered to Tom for him maybe
he can he can just oh that's true he can just extend it like I don't know okay wait weiner weiner dog compared to cat height okay okay height there we go oh yeah no I oh wait no wait wait okay uh wait sorry doxin cat height comparison oh yeah no I oh yeah no I think he might be I think he might be too too short I I got I'm looking at this picture right now and I'm like okay if this is a regular cat size and that is a regular leaner dog size then he may or may not be too short he might be a short king I think I think I don't know cat seems really tall like I think cat seems really really tall um rice thank you for the super chat thank you Some very determined cats can break these things so I don't know how well to defend against a hungry boy Okay,
so dad I don't think he knows how to open things yet Because like I know cats they have like They like to use their paws a lot Dad has figured out how to rotate stairs Like he hasn't figured out how to rotate stairs But he has figured out how to push stairs So I think like I think it'll be fine
He knows how to push things, but he doesn't know how to rotate.
So I think we're okay.
All right.
That seems, okay.
That cat feeder seems way too tall.
So I'm going to have to look at another one.
What other cat?
I don't want to use an ice pack.
I want like an actual fridge, fridge.
Meal time.
Okay.
Not a meal.
Wait.
Is that?
What was okay automatic cat feeder whip timer Six meals which one is the one where with That's not an ice pack.
I need a real I need a real fridge.
I don't want I don't want a fucking I don't want a fucking like ice pack shit.
I don't have space on my fridge for ice packs Oh, pineapple.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Congratulations on the channel reaching 100 million views oh my god thank you everybody holy shit 100 that's a lot of that's a lot of numbers numbers numbers numbers whoa wait oh my god it was even oh my god 100 million 100 million 28,000 views thank you guys I've almost uploaded a thousand videos oh my god I I'm terminally online I'm actually terminally online right now numbers go up stonks but thank you everyone thank you for the 100 million views i really appreciate it guys thank you so much all right okay guys today is because itchio is down it's shopping less it's it's shopping time for jokey right now because i need a better sleep schedule and to do that i need him the fucking i need him the fucking let me sleep all right up to six but this is for draft what food auto feeder all right what food auto feed that's like okay the only one i found that was an actual fridge was the was the really tall one the other ones are with an ice pack which i'm not really a fan of uh not really
fan of the ice pack ones because i really don't want to use an ice pack right now um what about this uh wet food automatic feeder five fresh meals for cat dog cat dog all right adopts advanced semiconductor refrigeration ship that continuously keep cooling wet food by simply polyking it in um can keep cat okay we'll do this one okay it's tiniere all right what are the reviews oh and it's like twitch prime sorry not twitch prime but hey guys you guys at twitch prime if you have Twitch Prime,
you can subscribe to your favorite streamer for one month for free on Twitch, guys.
Anyway, I have Prime.
I have Amazon Prime.
Alright, alright, I'm getting this.
The cat dog's not included, unfortunately.
Um, I'm getting this.
Oh my god, are they feeding the cat fucking sashimi?
What the?
Why is it?
Why is the cat getting sashimi?
That cat is fucking as hell holy fuck oh my god this cat is bougie as a fuck this guy has a sashim that's a fancy ass cat all right uh five meal compartments i like how it's like uh initial meal uh you should have dry food freeze food and wet food should be consumed wait wet food should be consumed within Excuse me,
it told me that I can keep wet food, it can keep it fresh within, oh, like when it's outside of the freeze.
Okay, we're going to try this out.
All right, what are the reviews?
There's, guys, okay, the only downside is that there's only 32 people that have left the review on this.
I'm a little worried.
32 people have left a review on it.
So I don't know if I should yeah, but the other ones with reviews Okay, the only okay the only thing that sucks is that The other ones with reviews.
Oh god, that looks fucking disgusting with the waifu in it
There's a 32 very it's not laziness.
I just want to sleep in the morning.
I just want to sleep in guys it's not laziness i'm so tired of waking up at 6 30 in the morning and then having him waking me up again at okay if he's gonna wake me up at 11 a.m i i would write i i want him i want him to skip the 6 30.
if i could get the automatic feeder in going at least i can like at least I can have a continuous sleep till 11.
Instead of waking me at 6.30.
And then waking me up again.
Look, I left elementary, middle, and high school.
I thought after graduating high school, I wouldn't have to wake up at 6 in the morning anymore.
Guys, I already went through this.
Time.
Okay.
I did my 630 time.
Graduating high school meant I wouldn't have to go through that again.
And I feel, yeah.
I did my part.
Make it sound.
You know, schools were originally meant to be built and or like built and set up to be like a prison.
right guys like that's like the original intent of schools they it was meant to like replicate a prison system I served my time
show it over oh yeah yeah I mean a factory environment I mean factory prison same thing all right I'm trying to figure out what I don't want to buy the I the only ones that are like with higher views are the ice packs but it's like I have to not only will I have to clean the machine like every like every time it's done every time I've used up all the feeding stations but I also have to refrigerate the ice like I don't want to fucking deal with that just give me one thing that I am willing to pay the money I am willing to pay for it all right the only one that seems to like have its own refrigerating system and also uh um and also has high reviews is the one that my it's a really tall one so am I gonna force that to extend his neck just to eat food it's very tempting.
It's very tempting.
Pour just a little morsely.
I'll be like, pure.
It's like I'm making it a sauce situation for him.
Like, do you want to eat or do you want to starve?
He's got to work for it.
He's like, hello, dad.
Are you hungry?
all right let's see all right i'm gonna i'm gonna buy this i'm gonna okay it has it has 760 i'm gonna okay i'm gonna read the reviews i'm gonna read the reviews just to be sure let's see
my brain is super rusty right now when it comes to talking
i don't know i think it's a mixture of both just because it's like for me it's early but for me it's early and like I feel like I'm super rusty right now all right absolute piece of junk it doesn't always open the feeder cat the apple ring the bell manually but the lid won't open manually you get the spinning wheel of death this is all while I'm standing beside it how on earth can you trust it to feed your bed when you are awake what a joke of a device zero stars okay maybe I shouldn't buy okay piece of junk do not buy um what is the other one was the okay not all of them is bad guys let's see uh do not buy it does not get cold enough this is not cold enough after a few days the food is sitting at 60 degrees it should be around four degrees this doesn't work for canned food and definitely would not work for raw the dishes are made of plastic which is bad Hero Grove.
Do not buy this frost made a plow.
Okay.
Guys, I don't think I can buy this.
I don't think this is a good thing to buy.
Dango, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Mother may I have some oats and see.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I just got back from hope you're having good streams.
Shout out to people who work in the fast food industry as I did.
So tired.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
uh power to you man um i hear it's i know it's like super stressful to work in the fast food industry too uh especially because like uh especially for and retail workers because like customers people are just so mean i mean so fucking mean this is why and then like then you have to be afraid because like ai is taking over a lot of jobs right now too uh guys i don't think the automatic feeder seems to be a good idea anymore what do i okay i'm gonna read the 32 star i'm gonna read the one that has 32 reviews
all right i'm gonna read the reviews for this i mean
okay there's one okay uh easy to use but return there's only two of these types of devices on the market and i originally opted for this one because it was cheaper i like that it had five feeding slots and i also like that the window remained open until the next time slot My cat is a grazer and I returned this one because it just wasn't cooling the food enough when I filled it with chilled food It was resting at 58 degrees Fahrenheit.
What is that in like real real temperatures?
What's that did not make believe make believe temperatures guys?
Okay 14 degrees and even after freezing the food before filling the slot it was at 52 degrees within 52 Fahrenheit.
What the fuck is 52 Fahrenheit?
52 Fahrenheit.
Your stupid make-believe temperatures.
Make-believe numbers.
11 degrees.
Okay.
So you're definitely warmer than a fridge.
It's not even in the heat of summer.
I don't know, however, that is very easy to set up.
Okay, then, like, what the fuck do I do?
Okay, what if I don't buy it on...
Okay, best automatic...
2,000 people are watching me try and figure out...
Like, try to figure out how to buy an automatic feeder.
Guys, this is a very important stream right now.
Automatic food.
Wet food.
Dispenser.
Society.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You should laugh that you're in HST.
So, seamless.
And what your sleep schedule was.
Which is your HST?
That's a...
Taxes?
is that HST for what the fuck is it is that the harmonized sales tax what does this fucking sales tax have to do with being less of a D gen thank you for this oh why eat time literally the first thing I it literally shows I was like use this calculator to find out the amount of tax that applies to sales in Canada I was like what what does taxes have to do with my thank you for the super chat thank you thank you all right okay five oh no that's a sponsor does anyone know of a smart wet food dispenser okay it's not cat advice but my dog is basically a cat sometimes i decide to stay on study and my family consider feeding the cat a bird in holy fuck all day wow such a chore feeding feeding of it's like feeding of family members just so can't stand a thought of her eating late is there what okay the pet liberal does you have any not really but you're always updating app okay it's no it's not they do have a dry feeder the food feels cold and my you happen to know the temperature okay oh my
god happy llama tech the fuck is it 600 true refrigeration 40 fair oh my god okay wait It's so cool.
It's just a, it isn't just a, oh my god.
Wait, what?
There is a $600.
$600.
Oh my god.
I might as well just use it to freeze my food.
Like, what the fuck?
This is a legitimately refrigerator.
So the one on Amazon.
And one on, there's one in Amazon that's like $200, but that's the one where people are saying was a bit faulty um oh is this the same one okay auto wet feet i'm gonna see if this is the same one okay i need the one what's the wet food one oh yeah this is the same one so the it was either the one that's 200 i like i wish that was my fridge 600 i might as well just put my own food in there Like,
but apparently, okay, wait, okay, so cool.
Refrigerated smart feeder.
All right, let me look this up.
Reviews.
I need a note.
So cool versus pet liberal.
All right, let's see.
There's a product review here.
All right, we're going to listen to this product review together, guys.
Welcome to the...
ultimate comparison between the two top wet food feeders that exist right now okay that is the happy llama tech and the pet libra wet food feeder my kitty they promise under 40 degrees fahrenheit underneath here what's that guys convert this mad this make-believe number for me refrigerated temp so you really can keep this running for multiple days at a time on top of that it holds six servings well keep in mind that the first serving is going to be fed to your pet immediately so you really only have four degrees that's really good and you can serve in this plastic container underneath I'm just gonna go straight to pros and cons you're traveling whatever is going on you can ensure that your cat is getting exactly what they need when they need it fantastic for feeding your cat you can manage them even when you're not at home and they are fantastic for feeding your cat through the day let's say you're working you're traveling whatever is going on you can ensure that your cat is getting
exactly what they need when they need it oh thank god that's like basically what i need right now has been such a wonderful sweetheart and i want to give him everything i can to make sure you have a cat now it's because he eats wet food okay you know like one of the medications for his kidneys okay i have to go to a different vet um i have to go to a different vet for um his medication because uh my vet was closed and it's called cementra and they're like they're like oh for your cat and i was like no it's a it's a dog my my my pet's a dog and he requires cementra so it's like this thing for his kidney and then they're like oh like it's like a and they're like oh we usually prescribe it for cats and they're like are you sure it's okay and i was like what what do you what do you mean i've been doing like that's what the hospital prescribed to me and then i didn't realize this because like yeah look at the box and where the box said it was like uh poor cats cementra and it was the same
but i didn't i didn't read the front of the box because i read the bottom the bottle doesn't say it was for cats but um yeah because apparently cats are more prone to kidney problems than dogs so like so they make this medication so usually it's given to cats just because like the medication like most most of the customers are for cats so that that did not win the genetic lottery unfortunately uh i'm so thrilled that i can give him fresh wet food right when he needs it,
not when I have the time to give it to him.
Now that I've gone over the differences between the two and broke down their features, I really want to go through the pros and cons real quick, and then I want to get into what I wish these did provide.
Pros for the Happy Lama Tech are that it actually does have six servings, even though the first serving is fed automatically, and that it truly is at refrigerated temperatures.
I trust that the food coming out to i mean that's good i don't want my food to start rotting food for my cat and expiring i don't want to grow mold and stuff as for a con i do wish it had the door like pet libra does so i could cover the food after a set period of time as this bowl is not cooled on either one as it's meant to come up to room temperature and so it means that any food that's in here too long you're listening to a review of what if I should buy a $600 dog feeding wet like wet food refrigerator like that's I was like am I really gonna spend $600 for my dog so I could sleep a little bit more that's what you're listening to right now but I've been working through that by making sure that the meals in this are small enough that he will eat them in time and if you are concerned about that at all since this does have six servings you can have it just rotate to an empty bowl to make sure they stop eating so you just do food empty bowl food he deserves it make it work like that
so you can make this work now for the pet libro i think the no there's no way dad wouldn't like it if he sees food he doesn't fucking care what it comes out of like he is so food motivated he doesn't fucking care like you can drop food and water and he'll fucking swim over there just to gobble it up oh is that by way he doesn't even he doesn't even like water too by the way but he will do it that you can completely control when the door opens and closes as it's opening right now oh he has he has followed a stranger for food that's how fucked up he is that like that is exactly how fucked up situation is he will follow a stranger if she has food feed him but i had played with that so it's on the wrong meal and the other thing literally a lady i told the story before a lady walked up to us and she also had like a dog with her and then she gave dad a treat and then she walked away and dad followed her.
What about that one is that it has that larger whisker-framed.
If she had a van, he will follow her into a van and then drive away and then I'll be like, goodbye.
Open first.
He is happy with either of these.
As for the con, I do not like how much warmer that food is.
It is okay.
So it's warmer.
Okay.
The other one is a lot, the cheaper one is a lot warmer.
Dad food refrigerator fun.
Penguin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And not only that, not only that, she like, joked about it.
The lady joked about it.
It's like, Kiki, what if I just take his leash?
Will he even, like, come back to you?
And then she, like, walked away with Dad with leash, and he didn't look back at me.
He didn't even hesitate or cared.
He would have been like, yes, that's my new owner now.
And then, like, the end.
all right okay so apparently my only choice is to spend 600 on a smart feeder i don't know do i oh my gosh i'm so like i'm i'm actually guys you don't understand i'm i'm so fucking tempted just for the fact that i can you just for the fact that he would not wake me up at six in the morning it's I'm so tempted just so I could sleep like at least three hours longer you don't understand I'm so desperate he's been he's been doing this for a week and a half now I'm so tired
I don't care if I have to, okay, I'm doing it, guys.
I'm, oh, oh, okay, I'll make a pull, I'll make a pull to just, if I should buy it.
Do I buy the $600 food auto feeder, auto fridge for my dog, so I can sleep for hours longer.
So I don't have to wake up at 6 a.m.
Here we go.
Here's a pull.
Will you enable me to make this purchase?
What's the warranty return window?
All right.
Warriors are expected to arrive.
We currently ship within.
Oh, wait.
I got never guys.
Never mind.
I forgot to.
read something very important guys guys I think our dream dreams of sleeping later has already been crushed because there was one important detail that I
missed it was some a very very important detail that I did not read in the terms and conditions all right Canada.
Maybe they have it in Canada.
Alright, let's see it.
Alright, automatic wet food feeder available in Canada.
Alright.
I've been using the catmate 1 with 2 cupiris for years and no issues.
What the fuck is catmate 1?
What is that?
Catmate 1.
one is it an actual fridge or it's an ice pack why is it all ice packs um the catmate feeders have five oh my god i don't want to use ice packs i just want an actual fridge wait mini fridge like i don't understand a mini fridge is like 20 a college mini fridge is like 25 How the fuck?
Just put that technology into an auto feeder.
When did it, why did it, why is it $600?
Can't be that difficult if I can get a college fridge for 25.
It needs to be.
That's just an app.
Oh, you're right.
I can just ship it to, I can just ship it to my PO box.
tax oh yeah it's like the it's like the pink tax but for they're so right though i i'm willing to spend so much for i swear to god like i don't know i don't know wait no actually a pet is much cheaper i was gonna say like because like uh children live much longer uh your kid make lives much longer as they slowly drain your wallet and drain your wallet i was gonna say i don't know What's more expensive to take care of a child or a dog?
But then I realized a child can live for a very long time
And they don't have to go to college And pets don't have to go to college But they make an income at some point If they make an income What if the child What if the child is stupid What if I can't I can't rely on them to become a content creator I can't I've already hit that lottery I don't think my child can also hit the lottery too I already sucked up all the luck and it's not even that much luck what if the child's boring what if they're not entertaining
Make them a Nepo Influencer
Influencer child or a spoiled dog I spent so much money on dad Oh my god
The moment I think the moment he broke his back was like Was the day he won the real lottery His life changed, and he realized it can get better if I just hurt myself.
Many.
Doki Bird Jr., the next Jaden Smith.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So literally, thank you for the super chat.
At 10 minutes saved net per day, X 365 days equals 60.83 hours a year.
How much is that physically worth?
60 okay that is a actually that is a lot that is a lot all right I'm buying it I'm buying the pull I've been enabled I'm making this purchase it only took me a we had spent an hour debating if I should buy a $600 fridge for my dog the math works out I saw a lot I don't really understand the math but I saw a lot of numbers in there and I was like that seems worth it Where the fuck is the link?
I don't remember.
Oh my god.
I don't remember what it's called.
Okay, wait.
I gotta look at my history.
It was like Lama some shit.
History.
He won.
He wins again.
If my mom told me she adopted me because I seemed easier to take care of than a doxin, I might crash out.
No, not gonna lie.
That's a villain origin story.
Patrick has said, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Look, if it's too tall, I'll buy him a little, like, you know, like those little, uh, I can't, you know, those little, like, the first thing I thought of, the little stepper, um, where you put, okay, so apparently, there's these little separate, separate things for,
to improve bowel movements, so, put like that people put um under their feet when they're on the toilet yeah i'll buy one of these for him so he can reach he can reach the the automatic feeder that don't sleep on those yeah okay for those who don't know uh to improve by you can eat these little uh if you have really bowel movements or bad toilet time I don't have one by the way I don't have one but I've read about it so it's this basically basically improves your posture for your colon health so you have these you basically put your put place your feet on top of these steppers and then you'll have a good time you'll
you'll have a better time recommended My doughkeeper.
The chat is...
See, look at that.
We have one happy customer from Rooney.
Chat is worth a get one today.
So anyway.
Anyway, we're gonna...
If it's too tall for Dad to dog feed it, I'll buy one of these little...
This little stool is for him.
So he could use this to reach the food.
Alright, I'm buying it right now.
My mat...
Wait.
My manager has not told me it's a bad idea, so I'm buying it.
He just said, you should adjust your title, but you can...
You know what, manager?
You can adjust my title.
I believe in you.
All right.
All right, let's see.
Where is it?
Refrigerator.
Oh, my God.
It's $600 American dollars.
That's the worst part.
The fact that it's an American dollars.
all right let's see do i get the stainless steel is it not stainless steel or red oh silicone lids not included okay plus six pack stainless steel all right check out all right okay i need to figure out where's my po box i need to order it send this in my PO box right now.
Alright.
United States.
What the fuck is my PO box?
Is this manager with us right now?
Miracle, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, they messaged me like an hour ago.
And was that you should change your title.
And I just ignored it.
Wait, what is the title right now?
Okay.
What did it adjust it to?
It just still says...
Oh, it's Shio down.
Alright.
I need to find my PO box real quick.
Oh my god.
I can't copy and paste this.
Just text.
I gotta...
I gotta look at my YouTube.
My YouTube has my PO box too.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Where is it?
Okay.
uh this 8120 research boulevard street austin okay so that's the correct one 78758 all right cool save nice pay now oh nice free shipping all right guys bought my 600 refrigerated smart I got so much money for my dog.
Oh, there was an issue processing your payment.
Can you- My credit card company was like, stop.
Are you sure?
Stop.
That universe might be telling me no, but that's not stopping me.
I want to sleep in.
I can't keep doing this.
I can't keep waking up at six in the morning.
The universe doesn't know.
I will brute force this payment.
Alright.
Okay.
They're like, if you do not initiate the transaction, please.
I gotta put on a code real quick, give me a sec.
Alright.
What is the code?
My one-time code to make this...
purchase all
right i should get it i've done it i've done it wait is it hello processing please wait was it declined please stop stop don't please why did it decline it
try again let your car was so glad all right let's try this again okay i will i have i have two more credit cards i i have two more credit cards to do this okay give me a sec i gotta get my other credit card oh wait my wallet's right next to me wait why is my wallet next to me me.
He can't stop me.
I need my sleep.
It's been two a week and a half.
I can't keep doing this.
I can't keep letting him wake me up.
Okay.
This is, I'll try this one.
That feeder will be mine.
credit card where is it
where the fuck guys oh my god too many cards guys no oh and they can do debit okay nice i'll use my debit card wait this guys if i show oh my god i'm gonna make a video about wait technically technically this is my video about the feeder so it's a business expense i'm gonna use my company card
it's technically a business expense i'm talking about this i'm talking about this feeder right now don't keep no I don't take my dog into a tax rate up.
He's in my videos.
He's my tax rate up.
All right.
Let's see.
Wait, that's a valid card.
It's my debit card.
Oh my God.
The universe is actually trying to stop me from making this purchase.
I don't understand.
This is actually the smartest purchase I've ever made.
I don't know.
understand why is it trying to stop me
please i'm desperate i just want to sleep i'm so desperate i just want to sleep i just need i need to sleep
sisters i don't have an expiration date on this guy this is my debit card how the fuck did I do a debit card guys I'm so sad maybe if I pay in in installments me oh never mind I won't let me pay this stuff my debit card doesn't expire all right guys
Wait.
Mind that this debit card doesn't Oh, wait, it's a client card How'd JK Sorry Sorry, sorry, I was looking at My client card.
I'm so, I'm so tired I was looking at My client card, not my Debit card
Whoops I was like, what?
Where's the?
And then I realized it was just my It was just my client card I when I put it in the machine and go okay guys I'll figure this out I'll figure out how to buy this later if I don't worry I'll figure out I'm so tired guys this is why I need my 600 dollar fridge I need I could sleep four more hours you don't understand he's been doing this for a week No,
I don't like that.
I think I need this.
I'll do anything to sleep four more hours.
But the sleep deprivation is kicking right now.
I don't know what else I can do other than sleeping early.
But it's like there's no solutions.
There's practically zero solutions.
this problem.
I think a few cases of monsters cheaper.
Rice, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It feels like there was no other option than to buy an automatic feeder that's also a refrigerator.
There's practically no other options than that.
Zero.
Where can we have There's no other I can't even see another solution for this It's the only Justifiable realistic Solution to my problem If I throw enough money at something It'll work
Financial self-sabotage In the HD
Oh yeah Oh yeah that reminds me I might Trying out, okay.
Don't judge me, okay?
Don't judge me on this.
But I've been like, okay, so you guys know how, okay, I know you guys are going to start judging.
The moment I said, don't judge me.
You guys are going to start judging me.
But anyway, so, you know how I do like pre-cooked meals?
But like, I'm not really a fan of my, because this is like this pre-cooked meal.
Like, it's only, they only work for my...
or in my city and but the thing is uh it's like i i'm not like a huge it's like hit or miss because sometimes sometimes they like they have a set menu and they don't there's no like variety to it like i mean there is sort of variety but like it's practically like it's very boring the dishes are like very boring and and um and it's mostly geared towards like western styles so all the dishes are just Western style dishes and um and um there's a very like if I don't like a particular meal that's on like Monday or Tuesday I just don't order it but it's been happening a lot recently where I just don't order much from the pre-cooked service um just because I'm just not a fan of some of the meals they're preparing for it like the photos they show and like what they're making for that day so I was talking to a friend about it and they're like Oh,
why don't you hire like there's like Personal chefs that you can hire To customize my menu And so I was like, you know what So I decided so I was like looking around And I was looking around And It's not that expensive It's not actually that expensive Guys,
okay It's It basically Basically It's also another company that does and it's sort of like the pre-cooked meal service but instead it's like uh instead you can customize your menu versus you know just having a set thing each week and then you just order you just order from from the pictures they send you and like the description what the meal is for monday tuesday wednesday thursday friday and because like i feel like i was already sort of wasting my money on the pre-cooked meals um on the pre-cooked meal only because like if i'm not satisfied with the meal i just still order out or i still order out and i still like um i still order out and i still like add more food to my to my um um for to my week just because i'm just not really a fan of the food itself so i was researching about it and they do offer there's like this from another company that's in my city this is also in my city and uh you know and i would do this i do this pre-cooked meal things because i want to eat healthier
too because when i order out for myself uh i order out myself i usually tend to avoid like you know i used to tend to avoid the healthy options and stuff like you know vegetables and stuff like that um because it's just it's not in the dish itself so when i looked at the personal chef option it was basically i paid like like a hundred and fifty dollars a week for my pre-cooked meals uh and for uh for the personal chef option it's 250 canadian dollars a week and uh and they send like personal like they customize the menu for you and they buy like fresh groceries on the day to to make your meals so i was like oh that's a i feel like that's a good deal because like sometimes if i order out If I order out and I order like an Uber Eats or whatever Sometimes I spend like $60 in one day You know,
so I was just like, oh It feels much more cheaper because Or like maybe I order, you know, I want to order something nice to eat and stuff So I order like, buy it, this is all Canadian So it's Monopoly money by the way
It's all, it's all Monopoly money still Canadian so so I figured it'd be a lot cheaper and for health reasons because like they're flat it's like you know they plan on doing like healthier options with like vegetables and um for my diet as well as like you know adding more dairy products too um and I just wanted like a customized menu that fits my that just fits my taste buds more so I feel like for 250 a week versus uh like versus like something i can actually like like for food i actually enjoy and yeah it's like getting a home cooked meal too that's something i miss as well for like dietary restrictions and stuff yeah so to get something like just something that i can have for like um instead of just ordering out no it's for lunch and dinner they make meals for I'm doing a trial period.
I'm going to be doing a trial period for it next week
The thing is I would love to like just Order groceries and just make my own meals, but I just don't have time.
I'm always so busy So it like so like ordering uber.
So you can see why a lot of content creators Everyone just like uber eats and like order takeout and it's so unhealthy.
It's very unhealthy long-term wise and that's but a lot of content creators do it because we just don't have a lot of time in our schedule um to cook for ourselves or to even like go outside to do grocery shopping that's why you see a lot of them which is like oh yeah I just ordered uh I just yeah I'm just waiting for my food right now and um yeah and it's such a waste of money that's also why I started doing pre-cooked meals because um it was just such a waste of money over time um always ordering all the time just because i can't go out and and like you know i just i don't have the time to go out to grab something to eat or go out to do grocery shopping and uh and like prepare my meals
oh no no i'm it's like there's i don't think fact i don't think factor works in canada i know there's like um i had some friends suggest like various pre-cooked meal service but it only exists in America.
Is there a service that does...
groceries?
Yeah, they deliver groceries.
But like I said, sometimes I just don't have time to...
I just don't have time to cook for myself sometimes.
Also, the dishes is so...
Why should I just...
It's so tiring.
Oh!
Oh, itchy is back up now.
Yeah, but I feel like...
It's weird to pivot back to itch.
It's still a lot.
Washing dishes is so...
Cleaning up and washing dishes is so tedious.
I do have a dishwasher, though.
I'm going to chat.
I don't know how to be an adult sometimes.
I think you guys might notice But I'm just doing I'm just doing a Trial period for like a week just to see how how I like it
I think it's cook unity.
I think cook unity was the one that my one of my friends suggested to try out But they don't have cook unity in In Canada
Yeah, I just need to build a routine.
I just need to build a routine.
But I'm going to try to trial period with the chef.
And just to see how it goes.
And if it's worth the investment.
Like, the only reason why I'm, like, trying it out.
It's because I just want to have a healthier eating style.
I just felt like, because, like, I spent so many years just ordering out because of streaming.
And, like, it felt, it was just felt so unhealthy in general.
I live with my when my parents sorry when my parents live with me because I paid the rent when my parents live with me um even then my parents would just like order food for me like I never I didn't really get like home cooked meals they would just go out and just buy me something like they would go out to eat and just buy again I would be streaming or working and they would just um um and they would just like buy me something to eat And I didn't really get like home-cooked meals.
And even when I did get like home-cooked meals, it'll just be like something super unhealthy.
Like, you know, be like spicy noodles or like bulldog noodles or like udon.
Or udon, but like not the healthy type of udon.
Like there's a lot of like unhealthy ingredients in the udon and stuff.
And stuff like that.
And I just felt like...
I just felt very unhealthy because Because I felt like I felt like Doing that for so many years It felt like it was really bad for my body So that's why I'm trying out this personal chef Because I tried with the I tried with the pre-cooked meals But I was just It was a lot healthier It was a lot healthier and the portions were really good but but I felt like I was so bored with the variety it just felt the meals just felt so boring and like it was like at one point it just repeated itself like you know I was getting the same meals not like every week but like you know they like uh recycle the same recipe and stuff the same recipes and it wasn't like my favorite recipe too so so that's why I'm like okay I'm gonna try out this maybe like having a more customized menu would be my taste and like you know having something more customized every week might be you know might make me follow a better routine
yeah well it's not really a personal chef chef because like I think she she does like because it's a company too so they offer this apparently But it's more so like you can have a Customized menu for what you want to eat
So it was it's like it's like 250 a week basically for the entire week $250 Canadian so But yeah, like it's just a trial period No, they just bring the food over they they basically they basically meal prep they meal they're basically meal prepping for me because it's not like every day it's not like they're cooking every day from what I read it's yeah for both lunch and dinner it's for both lunch and why does she emphasize Canadian cash is it less yes it is yes money has not been doing very well uh so it's like why does she keep emphasis yes because our currency sucks i always when i do sponsors i only accept us dollars right they're like you want to be paid canadian or america i was like no american dollars please i i have american bank accounts just so i can accept american cash the canadian money Canadian to USD okay 80 CAD to USD so 58 US dollars is 80 Canadian dollars so like whenever I buy Steam games I always be like every time I buy Steam games not
so bad yeah but the thing is I knew what it was like before it got that bad i i knew what that was like before i knew we were very our currency was very similar to us currency and then i remember those times i the fact that it's just the fact that like i knew when it used to be good
so it feels worse That's so much worse.
So we used to be there with you.
Wait, no, they're planning on.
We're planning on.
It's like, I think like from what I read on the website, it's a more customized menu, but they are like, it's also sort of like meal prep too, where they do make like food in advance for some days.
So like, and all you have to do is just reheat it.
so it's not like every day is like they cook it fresh every day um it's like they're all it's also sort of like meal prep and too i don't know i don't know we'll see we'll see how it goes if i don't like it i'll go back to the pre-cooked meals it's just more if i go back to pre-cooked meals it's a hundred dollars cheaper and um yeah it's a hundred dollars cheaper and i know what i'm getting like every week but it's just more so of like i just want to try and be more healthy in terms of With the time I have,
I just want to try to be more healthy.
Yeah, and I get to have it more tailored to what I want to eat and stuff.
But imagine cooking for yourself.
I'm very limited to what I can and can't cook.
Yeah, I want to next up, like, I do want to start being more, like, be more active with exercising and stuff too.
I've just been so busy.
It's been really tiring lately.
That's something I want to move up to as well.
For those who don't know why I'm like a little bubble child, it's because I was a bubble child.
For those who actually don't know, who are more newer to my streams or newer to me, growing up, growing up, I was very, very sheltered.
um so like so like all my parents wanted me to do was study study and um and uh do after school like and just do after school activities like participate in sports or do clubs and stuff like that like do anything to be to like up my college resume like up my like college application so
middle school to high school was mostly like extra yeah extracurriculars it was just studying in extracurriculars so i wasn't allowed to touch the stove until i graduated high school because then they're like oh she has to live by herself yeah i was an only i i am an only child so they're like they wouldn't let me touch the stove or like the oven or anything they wouldn't let me like touch anything that requires fire so um i never learned how to cook until i graduated high school because at that time they're like oh shit like she has to live by herself so we have to teach her how to operate a stove so that's when i first learned how to cook and um and because they're like i didn't have to do chores because they're my parents were like just study or like do you know do your extracurriculars or like because i culture my entire time every week was basically uh basically i was either you know i was either doing my doing sports stuff like doing like you know,
I was in soccer, volleyball, basketball, soccer, basketball, volleyball, and field.
So I was in the team for all of those sports.
And so, you know, it would be like two hours of practice after school whenever it's soccer season or basketball season.
So my entire year was basically like I had clubs to go to.
I did a lot of different clubs.
It was just all to like, you know, did community service a lot i uh i um i had i won i for two years in a row for two years in a row in middle school i had the most community service hours done out of the entire uh middle school so i was just like yeah i was like college application maxing yeah i did shot put discus and javelin for the track and field team um i also got the track team but then I was like no because I hated running I hated running they're like you got into the track team I was like no I rap I rather throw
I rather throw I don't want to run I don't but then you're like wait but you were I was the goalie in soccer I did not have to run.
Because I had, that's why I was really good at FPS games.
Um, I was really good at FPS games because I had, uh, yeah, running for fun.
Are you fucking crazy?
Like, are you Tau Lulu?
Like, running in my free time?
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Anyway, so, um, that's why I was really good at, that's why I'm really good at FPS games.
because i have really good hand-eye coordination in general so uh my hand-eye coordination is really really good so that's uh so which helps a lot in playing video games too so i was the goalkeeper and then um for basketball i was i told for those who didn't know uh i talked about this before but i was i played center for basketball even though i wasn't the tallest but it's because I could jump really high and I also it's not that much running because it's smaller the court the court is a lot smaller versus like actual running I was really good at rebounds like when I had to grab the rebounds I basically can out grab out grab rebounds for like against other teams because I can jump really high um that'd be like
um um so yeah so basically my time a lot of my free time was spent on you know it's crazy i used to go outside so much now look at me now it's like it's like uh it's like it's like it's like groundhog day where like people like oh is the groundhog coming up it's like me i'm like oh my today we might find out if Doki is gonna come out of her cave of her little hole if she comes out of the hole that means there's uh and she sees her shadow that means we're gonna have winter's gonna end soon so um anyway anyway um so yeah like i wasn't allowed to do much adult learning stuff like actual like learning how to be an adult because my parents sheltered me so much growing up like i didn't have to do laundry like they're like you know i don't have to do laundry i didn't have to clean anything um all i did was just focus on my studies and focus on my extracurriculars or and also like get be on the pc too um and also like you know Be able to be on the PC and stuff.
So, um...
Um...
So, because of that, I didn't learn a lot of life skills growing up.
And even as I got older, um...
Even as I got older, and, you know, I went to college, I had to learn a lot of these things.
Um, like...
I had to learn a lot of, like, life skills stuff.
Um...
Like, uh...
within like a week basically before I had to live by myself so like my mom was trying to teach me how to do laundry and and like teaching me how to operate the stove well when I was like
18.
no I had to learn a lot of this when I was 18 basically like actual life skills um and like and I didn't even really and they but they never really taught me how to clean general.
And even then when I was in college, my parents would visit me like every couple of months just to check up on me too.
So I was like very sheltered and stuff.
So they'll be and then if they see it's dirty, they'll just clean up my place.
And then, you know, when I started living by myself after college, my parents moved in with me.
I still pay the rent too by the way I paid the rent After college My parents moved in with me And because of that You know I learned even less I learned even less on how to I didn't even learn how to Take care of myself
And then now Now I live by myself and uh i live by myself but i was sort of like thrusted into learning how to live by myself and how to deal with the adult world because my parents never taught me how to do taxes or anything or like how to actually clean my apartment
so i'm trying to learn how to be an adult step by step and all this happened like and it's been a year it's been it's been a year since then since i started living by myself like actually living living by myself and uh figuring out how to do all of this very late in life yeah i had to grow up very fast
uh patria sir thank you a super chat thank you thank you i still don't have a rice cooker though i i still don't i still don't i still don't have a rice cooker look i said step by step okay step by step you're doing the best you're doing your best and we're proud of you for sticking your guts and getting better bit by bit thank you a super chat thank you thank you thank you
Thank you.
You came a long way.
We're proud of you.
Thank you.
I'm really glad that I'm learning how to be an adult, even though it's it's taking a while.
Oh, no, Throne refunded it.
For those who are like, oh, but didn't someone try to buy a rice cooker?
No, Throne refunded it.
Even the universe doesn't want me to have a rice cooker because they're like, oh, there's a price difference between like the currency.
that the person bought it in and um what it was in canadian dollars so they're like they're almost like no there's like you gotta pay extra you gotta pay the extra for for the product or we're gonna refund it and i was like okay i guess you'll refund it aka
they didn't give us a super chat thank you thank you it's just destined guys is also by the way have you forgotten you can make microwave I don't need a rice cooker I can just make it in the microwave chat
Gus thank you for the super chat thank you thank you and I accept the drag food and marriage what like why get a house husband when I can get an IE who wants to be my IE
dango thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
couldn't buy it couldn't buy it so either see cooker tries to buy a dog feeder instead and then say to cook rice and um is a rice cooker gonna let me sleep an extra four hours i don't think so
Zechra.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
At this rate, Tokyo is scaling up to cook one minute rice in 59 seconds, guys.
Thank you, super chat.
Thank you.
All right, I have an Ayee.
That's what I call it.
That's like, for those who don't know, Ayee is like usually what you call uh because in asia you would have like living maids uh well they don't have to be living but uh my grandparents oh i live with my grandpa in asia like we had an ie and they're like it's called like we call it like i call it ie and um they're like living maids with him uh with my grandparents and she was so nice she would like make me she would make me like uh like dishes i like whenever we eat at home
yeah not i don't know it was like nanny but um because she was there before i lived with my grandparents when i used to live in asia
honey thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i can't believe they stole my money i'll buy another one from a different brand thank you for the
I don't know when I guess I guess they're saying Ichio is back on that now but I feel like at this point at this point it might be a little too late to go back to do Ichio stuff I'll do another I'll do it next week I'm sorry that like there's a lot of delays for the dokey jam stuff but I'll do it I'll do the checking it out next week I just want to hang out and chill you guys and like de-rust from chatting I feel so rusty talking.
Oh my gosh.
I think it's just because I haven't done a chatting stream in a long time, just because of how busy I've been.
It's just nice to just hang out with my drag wounds and just chat with you guys.
Just, you know, chill out.
Yeah, I'm de-resting right now.
I need to learn how to yapp again.
Oh, oh, no.
oh yeah did you guys see the the uh i i never keep up with nintendo direct because they're always so fucking early and you know i i'm not even a human at that time when they do the nintendo direct but i thought it was really funny because like their closing their closing trailer was um their closing trailer was for fire emblem and everyone was like people were like so disappointed or like oh my god but like it's but like it's only NA that's uh disappointed um at fire emblem because people like no apparent no one cares in NA about fire emblem but the thing is fire emblem is like one of the best-selling series that nintendo has ever done but only in asia
It's like, it's their best-selling series, but like, in Asia, like, in NA, like, it's not as pop.
I think, I think, I don't know why, though.
There's, like, because, why is Fire Emblem not popular in, um, in NA?
NA's too stupid.
you know what i'm so salty about they never make a localization for yokai watch i'm so sad about that i've always wanted to play um i think they only did like they only done the ds games but they didn't do like a console yokai watch localization and that makes me so sad i fucking i want i love watch anime series I've always I've always wanted to try to console games out
Patrick has to think of a super chat thank you thank you because it went from being essentially a smash IP to being everywhere and the swarming half of smash DLC I guess that's what makes the smash people I heard someone I saw a tweet was like smash smash the irreparable damage to five
What is Yo-Kai Watch?
It's basically...
Okay, Yo-Kai Watch was actually so fucking popular in Asia.
Because when I used to live in Asia, it was everywhere.
Like, there was so much merchandising.
And, like, there was so much merchandising and collabs of Yo-Kai Watch coming out.
When it was...
When it first came...
Like, when Yo-Kai Watch first came out.
It was literally everywhere.
It was huge.
It was basically, like, the next Pokemon.
back then and um but then it never got the localization or the popularity um that it deserved in NA and now I don't know now I feel like I feel like yokai watch fell off really hard because I don't think they like capitalized on it well like Pokemon they didn't like I guess they didn't like they didn't release enough games to capitalize off of yokai watch it was technically known as
I think my favorite, my favorite yokai and yokai watch was, I talked about it before, but my favorite yokai and yokai watch is manji mutt.
Because it's like, it's basically, it's what he looks like.
It's basically a salary, like a dog with the face of a salary man.
And then it like, It like Yo-Kai evolve into Dan Doodle and this is what Dan Doodle looks like.
I fucking, I love, I love Main Jeep.
And so this is, okay, this is Yo-Kai Watch and it Digi-Volves into Dan Doodle.
And this is what Dan Doodle looks like.
It's like, it's my favorite Yo-Kai because he looks so, he looks so fucking stupid.
fit um oh wait wait wait okay and then he evolves okay oh wait there's multi mud what's the difference between multi mud and dan doodle okay wait what the fuck is wait then how does okay is one of the yokai required to unlock dan doodle i love dan doodle yeah he evolves to rich I guess he bro went from salary man to influencer yes it was it was everywhere I would go to a mall and then it was just yoga wash everywhere in the mall attractive young dog and then he and then he discovers and then reality hits him and then he becomes a salary man Oh,
yeah, this is before he and then he gets promoted to become CEO This is my favorite yokai
He reached his P Level 1 salary man versus level 100 CEO Oh my god, wait, I saw someone tweeted about this But apparently if I said Alexa or
Okay, someone, okay, someone made a joke because like apparently some apparently people watch Watch streams with speakers on next to next to Alexa and then someone was like Alexa A pause just in case for you guys order 5,000 Water bottles and then some people's Alexa's actually ordered I'll pause just in case
5,000 water bottles And they had their credit cards connected to the Alexa And people had to People were freaking out You nearly activated it You Alexa Order one water bottle There There you go.
At least...
Okay.
Uh, Corga, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alexa, say, but um, but um.
Alexa, subscribe to Doki Bird.
Alexa.
No,
you triggered my voice.
No, you triggered my Alexa gift, tenant, merch.
Memberships to Doki Bird.
Alexa, play a Doki Bird video.
I changed the commander.
Alexa, buy Doki merch.
Alexa, play the Spatito.
This is why you never use...
Alexa, play Five Nights at Freddy's.
But yeah, I thought I was She just keeps saying But this is why you don't This is why you should change the command word To not Alexa Thanks, don't get I said I told Alexa to buy one water bottle There is no way There's no way I maxed out your credit card From buying one water bottle Alexa,
play Five Nights at Freddy's by Doki Brit on YouTube.
We can only afford one.
I had point 50.
Where is this water bottle from?
Did you buy it from like Gucci?
There's no...
Okay, water bottle, Freddy.
is some people live on their edge it's like 197 that's that's cheaper than a coke Alexa buy a coke okay coke price one cat bro that's cheap cheaper than McDonald's.
Alright.
One can of Coke is how... Oh wait, never mind.
One can... It's $1 for one can of... It's like 57 cents more.
But a water bottle can contain more water.
Damn it, Fry.
Oh, no.
Alexa, bye.
Buy me one can of Coca-Cola.
Instructions unclear.
I have paper pills.
Not the water, too.
Alexa, buy a Bugatti.
I don't think Alexa can.
Can you buy a Bugatti right now?
Buy a Bugatti.
Bugatti.
Bye.
Bouguette for a sec.
Can I actually, like, online buy a Bouguette?
Okay, I just encourage you to buy superly expensive cat food.
Hey, little cat food.
I was like, cool cat food.
Thing would be any better with my TV.
Thank you for this super chat.
Thank you.
How much is a Bouguette?
Bouguette.
92 Bouguette vehicles for...
Oh, no.
You can't just online.
order Amazon order a house I'm just like where do I put put it though you can literally buy it like a like buy like a house with a bathroom on Amazon and there's free delivery guys look at that prefab tiny home for sale 40 feet portable portable tiny house to live in for adults with three bedrooms oh my god for where do I just put it like in the fucking mountain I just,
oh my god, wait, this shit looks nice.
This is a, this is a house from Amazon?
It is nicer than my apartment.
You wouldn't download a house.
I mean, for 13K to live in this, I might as well.
Put it in somebody's backyard.
Don't trust me.
Are there reviews?
Wait, this is nicer than my house and my apartment.
We're 13k and there's free delivery.
Holy shit, what the fuck am I?
Stable for large families.
No insulation, poor plumbing.
Yeah, but...
But look at it.
I'm pretty sure Mennonese.
Oh, no, it comes with one fully equipped bathroom and kitchen.
Oh, my God.
The kitchen and bathroom is fully, like, fully equipped, too.
All I need is, I think the expensive part is the land.
All I need is land, which is, I don't know, 50 grand to a million, maybe.
oh what a deal guys but if i just have a random house in the middle of the in the forest i don't have to pay for land the state owns the land there's a tiny investment in land you know what if i just okay but to be fair if you have a house in the middle of like the forest or the mountains like Who's gonna find how how who's gonna find you but how would they know How would they know how would the state know that you live in there
We're gonna do android I'll still pay my taxes All right are the forest rangers really gonna patrol everything in the forest Forest is big.
They can't catch me.
It's a big-ass forest.
There's no way they can they can find they can like patrol at all.
They can't whoops.
And how the fuck do people go off grid?
It's not off grid if they're still in the grid.
They have Yeah, but they're not gonna look for me
Alright, what else?
I don't think I can buy some crazy shit on Amazon I didn't have portable house Porto What are some crazy shit you can buy
You can't You can technically buy a piece of land From Sealand I remember one time I stream i was technically one time i stream i was tempted to get knighted at sea land what country can you buy land off of so i can be sir dokey bird wait how much is it anyway to get knighted become a sea land noble today look i can be sir dokey i could literally be sir dokey right now they have the noble title bundles for couples family and corporate i'll show you guys
here i can be a sir dokey bird like right now i could buy for only wait it was it's only 75 lord and late oh lady do oh i could okay i could be a the the duchess of the the duchess dokeybird dame dokeybird lady dokeybird oh wait no there there's corporate bundles imagine you're like at a corporate party and they're like um you did so well today here's your bonus you're now you're now dutch dokeybird of sea lad congratulations on your bonus
is a recognized country they are the small the world's smallest state for those who don't know see that is like what is it it's like it's like a fucking a military fort for built by the UK and then one family was like it's like it's an oral yeah it's an oil rig in the middle of the ocean it's sea land Battle for C-Land Sovereignty Is this actually the official government?
Oh, it is.
It's government.org.
C-Land today.
Today's C-Land brings together a thriving community from all over the world who unites through a shared philosophy of freedom, self-determination, and adventure to help grow.
We proudly offer C-Land's noble title initiative.
All right.
Where's like individual become...
Okay, do I want a knighthood?
Guys, do I want a knighthood?
It should be Taka.
There is no way a Vatican City is smaller than a fucking oil rig.
There's no...
Okay, is Vatican City smaller than Sealand?
No, Vatican City is not smaller than Sealand.
Vatican City is approximately 0.5%.
17 square miles and it's uh while sea land is much smaller uh okay but how big is sea land it is 0.0004 square kilometers it's literally yeah i was like there's no i went i visited a vatican city and i swear to god it is not as small as you guys think it is all right guys do i want to be the
Sir?
I won't be sir.
I don't want to be dame.
The bet.
Guys, it's on the New York Times.
Best gift buy from in the New York Times.
The principality of Sealand.
I can be.
I can be the baron of Sealand.
The Duchess of Sealand.
Lady of Sea Land or Sir of Sea Land.
Okay, wait.
Official Sea Land website.
Yeah, this is actually the official Sea Land.
Okay.
I want to be officially knighted.
Alright.
Where to buy.
Okay.
Literally sea land.
Sea land is the old...
Buy cert for...
Knighthoods for sale from royal titles.
Wait, what's this?
Your purchase also supports or...
What is included?
Wait, what is this?
Uh...
Pomerania?
What the fuck is Pomerania?
Wait, I can buy land in Germany?
Pomerania and leave is that a dog yeah no I'm looking okay as a historical region and modern geographic area in northern gender jet Germany and Poland wait what the fuck is this wait even the Germans are selling knighthood by
now wait I get a meadow from this.
Poor life choices with Doki.
Wait, it's only 290.
Time to make Doki law in the reality.
Solid.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
First son, Ben.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The student should be at poor life choices with Doki.
guys it says bye now i can be i can be the by genuine german title oh my god i can be the archduke of pomerania and levon where the fuck is pomerania and levonia
it says it says genuine
It's oh wait, I like this It's a grand dukedom of Pomeranian Le Bon Order titles legit Does not historically, okay, what was it?
Someone was like, it is somebody's fantasy micro nation I was like, okay, so this is all just role play I see you guys, but for C-Lan C-Lan's real, I recognize them as a real country country used to be able to buy land off of sea land but I think because too many people bought oh my god I could buy the sea lands constitution I think too many people bought the like bought pieces of sea land that they had to like stop because like there's no more sea land to offer I left my room for 10 minutes and some Korean told my Alexa to play five Knights at Freddy's on YouTube?
Buy a cat of cola and buy a damn food.
Who could have done such a thing?
Alexa, please play Five Knights at Freddy's on YouTube.
Oh, Alexa, please buy a knighthood from Sea Land.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, guys.
What do I get?
Do I want to be the baroness of SEALAND the lady slash Lord of SEALAND?
Sir dokeybird of SEALAND the Countess of SEALAND or the the Duchess of SEALAND
The baroness is a duchess.
I could be sir and duchess.
I could be the Duchess of dokeyland.
Please buy a rice cooker.
You become a noble.
Does that mean a defense to you?
Like, did they ever come under?
No, I'll just flee to a neighboring country.
As all nobles do.
You think we go...
You think we...
We're in the front lines.
We just flee to a neighboring country.
And restart our life.
Be like, oopsie.
Dory.
oh my god to be a duchess is a thousand dollars why is it okay guys we can't be the duchess of sea lad it's a thousand dollars what the fuck is this this is a make okay like it's paper why is this paper a thousand no wonder you guys want me to oh my god i can get an id card I it is the best one so who would okay if I find this okay our highest rank oh it's the highest rank of nobility it comes with uh it comes with luxury luxury parchment deed of title featuring embossed gold coat of arms your title deed personally signed by the sovereign prince Your name is Michael Prince Michael of Sealand premium frame to display your title deed Premium document holder with embossed code of arms my god the prince of the prince of Sealand Sealand history and information pack personalized proof of title gold card and photos of the principality Guys,
I could get a physical e-citizenship card preview, guys.
Oh my God.
Wait, I could get a personalized sea land.
Guys, what if I change my business email to be a dokeycanread at sea landlord.org?
Like, what if I change my official email to have sea landlord.org?
it's such a bad idea it's so so bad my personal ebook this is like god business inquiry don't he can read at sea landlord.org I feel like I feel like when like sponsors try to reach out to me they'll be like are you sure this is a real email why is this a sea land at the end
because you're doing business with royalty it's the duchess of sea land
must begin with your fault i'll be like if you wish to email me you have to refer to me as duchess dokey bird of sea land like dear duchess dokey bird of sea land i would like to be quiet Whenever my staff replies to an email, they have to have like the code of arms at the You would actually screw over your sponsor opportunity Oh my god,
I could be like Sealandduchess.org Has one gigabyte of wow Oh my god, so much One gigabyte of storage is so much Yeah, every email needs to be formatted like a formal letter
Guys, all right Okay, either I become a sir dokey bird or the touch All right, new Paul, new Paul, do I become Sir dokey bird or touch his dokey bird?
New ball.
I love you guys, but I got P. I'll be right back.
I'm back.
Mr. Broken Bond.
Then you have the Super Chat.
They think, imagine being the only actor.
Exactly!
I would be the first official duchess in V-tubing history.
We're gonna make history, guys.
I'll be the first official noble V-Tuber.
Like, they can all pretend.
They're like, you know, there's like V-Tubers who are like, yeah, I'm royal.
But are they really?
Do they have a certificate to prove their royal language?
They don't.
I'd be the first one in V-Tuber history.
I would be the first officially recognized noble V-Tuber.
With a coat of arms
Whenever they announce me They have to refer to me as Duchess of Sea Land
We are here to welcome The Duchess of Sea Land Don't Keep Bird To the stage
Kayla from Holland Is a Baroness of Sea Land She already did it Ellie, thank you, that's why I got to be a duchess.
It's higher.
Yeah, but the Baroness, the Baroness is at the bottom of the royalty tier.
It's at the bottom of the royalty, royalty tier list, guys.
It's Baron, Lloyd, Sir, Count, and then Duchess.
I outrank her.
I would be the highest ranked nobility
I paid I paid a paid a noble
alright guys oh my god 61 am I actually gonna do it I actually gonna become the Duchess of Sealand for a thousand dollars my manager didn't message me to stop okay Tyler Okay, I want... And I want an ID card, too.
Okay, dokeybird.
Title holder's full name.
Do what you're doing, your highness, the stream is lit as fuck.
Yeah.
All right.
Dokeybird.
Title holder... That's my full name.
Look, it's the highest rank of nobility.
It has a luxury...
parchment deed of title it has embossed gold coat of arms it's embossed guys that's when you know it's more official that oh my manager went to sleep it's over all right uh i would like an id card as well please add an id card to i want i want an official id card of my of seal from sea land because she cannot be stopped
all right check out wait does anyone have a coupon code for sea land guys guys who has a who has a coupon code for sea land that i can use
Alexa, stop it.
I need a coupon code.
Does anyone know a coupon code?
What's the ID photo?
What if it's just the face?
Cosmos, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, I'm going to look up.
C-Lan coupon code.
30% off Sea Land Gov. Okay, Noble 10.
Oh my god.
It allows military members to get 10% Okay, all right.
Oh, technically, since I'm becoming the Duchess of Sea Land, technically I'm in the military.
Alright.
Does that actually work?
Does this coupon code work?
It lasts just 10.
Oh my god, it works.
Guys, it works.
It allows military members to get 10% off no technically technically I'll be part of the sea land military by being a note by being a nobility for sea land guys I get 70 get 10% off no
all right we're happy shopping with this way code enjoy wait that's 25% off How do I get that?
It's loading my coupon.
I'm pretty sure that's illegal.
Okay, click to copy code and okay, save.
Oh, wait, 25% off.
All right, let's try this.
25% off.
Save 25.
Okay, that's invalid.
Don't keep that stolen.
Okay, okay, I won't use that code What's a code that that can use
Solent Valor is a crime In Sealand?
They're in international waters I think anything they do Who even is in the Sealand military?
I feel like only like one person Can actually use that code Okay you're not I will be soon soon after I pay for it after I pay for my after I pay for my ID card I'll soon be a citizen of sea land I'm paying for my citizenship guys there's no such thing as international law but there's this one?
E citizen 15% off.
Oh, 15% off?
Wait, I want 15% off.
Okay, does this work?
Guys, I got oh, it's a, never mind, I didn't get 15% off.
I got lied to.
Where the fuck?
Okay, why is this is 50 30 percent uh which code what does this for duchess bird zekra thank you for the super chat thank you thank you you're talking to a future sea land soldier so some respect many thank you for the super chat thank you thank you guys i'm trying to look for a coupon code right now there has to be why is it verified yesterday lied okay i need a coupon okay sea land I need the best coupon code for C-Land.
Guys, give me a coupon code that works.
10% or more.
So I can be the Duchess of C-Land.
No, it'll be great.
Okay, guys, I swear to God, if my credit card goes through for this and not for my auto-peat it, then the universe knows what's the universe has its Priority straight like
I I want to know I want to know if like if my card can would let me buy this versus versus a fucking Fucking auto feeder for my dog
All right
Somebody call that twitch lawyer.
Toki's gonna commit fraud again I'm just trying to become royal.
I'm trying to pay for it.
But first up, I'm trying to find a coupon code that allows me to get.
All right.
There you go.
I found it.
All right.
Wait, it's 700.
Wait, why does it say a thousand earlier?
It's not seven.
Oh, nice.
It's only, guys, it's only seven.
This is the stupidest Guys, it's almost the same price as the auto feeder, guys It's It's actually, it's almost the same price as the auto feeder That's like crazy
Alright, if my card Let's me buy this Over my my dog feeder then the universe knows what's up this is this is the universe telling me something this is the will of the universe don't do this okay we'll buy one for dad too okay what does should we make dad sir dad he could be a knight please don't get dad oh my god you're right guys Okay,
Lord Dad, Sir or Sir Dad?
Sir Dad or Lord?
Sir Dad, okay, become a net, sir.
Okay, sir.
Uh, premium frame.
I would like it to be framed and signed by Prince Michael, please.
I- Yes, I would like it to be signed by the Prince.
Okay.
Daddy.
okay do you want to be do you want his full name dokey dokey amber doge
that is a noblest of nice
all right add to cart i have i'm gonna have it framed and signed by the prince michael himself That's my night.
Alright, check out, I'm ready.
I agree with these terms and services.
Okay.
Alright, if my card goes through, it was willed by the universe.
It was fate.
It was destiny.
Yeah.
It is truly destiny.
If my card doesn't get declined, it was written in fate.
It was meant to be.
Every moment led to this.
All right.
This is it.
I'm paying now.
It's processing.
Okay, Aerith's wanting me to put a code on it.
I haven't been to church, but please, God.
All right.
Let's see, where's my one-time passcode?
And three.
You can still stop this.
three, two, one.
It
offered tribute, Duchess Dokey Bird, Palmberry Park.
Thank you for the Akka soup.
You are now referring to the Duchess of Dokey Bird.
I'll see that now.
We're not the same.
It is so tap.
And, sir, Doki Ambertoge.
Lawglim Duchess Doki print.
And it's signed by the Prince Michael.
I have it.
It's going to be framed and embossed by the Prince Michael.
I am official royalty now.
Lawglim Duchess Doki print of C.
the fact the fact that i was able to buy a a nobility title my card lets me buy something from fucking sea land but not a fucking dog feeder for my dog it was
It wouldn't, it wouldn't even live, my god was like, no, no, no, we're gonna decline it, no, no, no, no.
See, that is more repute, see, guys, see, that is officially recognized by my credit card company.
I, this is not Ichio's fault.
We will play, if Ichio was knocked down, I would not have gotten into this rabbit hole.
Marty, thank you for the five gift gifts, thank you, thank you.
Black talent, thank you for the magenta soup, thank you, thank you.
Time to pay taxes to Duchess Bird now, thank you for the secret I guess I am the highest form of nobility now.
I am the Duchess of Ceylon.
Duchess Doki Bird.
Marty, thank you for five gift and gifts, thank you, thank you.
Do I get an official email?
Wait, let me see.
I can't believe it.
actually went through.
I thought I was going to get Kartiklad.
The Principality of Sea Land has confirmed.
I will now, I will officially be, okay, I'm going to tweet it.
This is me where officially quite literally dragons.
Zechra, thank you for the Hakasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
By subscribing, you're officially in the Sea Land military.
you if anything happens to see that you will be drafted to protect the the principality of sea land you gotta protect the duchess i pledge myself as a loyal vessel the duchess don't keep rid of sea land but where's the i'm like thinking do i if i if i tweet this out do i hide the price I'm gonna blur it I'm like thinking or do I live I live with my live with my actions you said like do I just should I should I hide it so I won't be shame or or do i show it to everyone
you better show that price don't hide your shame touch a stokey brain thank you for the super chat rice thank you thank you it's official guys look look guys wait let me see let
me uh let me uh save this real quick don't worry i'll post the uncensored version
guys look it's official
look it'll also be a framed it'll be a framed too
I am an official Duchess And dad is official knight now He's officially knighted He's an official knight Guys I still can't I can't believe it I'm so dumb I can't believe it
And it's signed and framed by Sir, the Prince, the Prince of Sealand.
What an honor.
Now that's her touches, Oshi.
Truly is such an honor to be behold me.
The fact that it's framed and signed.
by the prince michael
it's too late i already made my purchase i don't think i could change anything
wait wait let's see oh wait actually
let me make sure that i did it correct okay i might have to change i have to contact them to change it because because i actually sort of i paid less for the eco i want to be like hey i want to change my order i i actually paid for the non-signed version for dad i mean like um sir i actually want to give you more money because i forgot to pay for the version where dad also gets the side version i be like um i actually want to pay more
Guys, if I'm gonna have it sign a frame bite from Chris Micah, I also want dad to receive that too.
I...
Jokey.
Dad also deserves it as well, guys.
He also deserves good things in life.
All right, let me get ready to make my tweet.
My very financially...
Alright.
Alright, give me a sec.
Let me get this ready, make this tweet ready, and then we'll call it here.
the stream look if it was never down this wouldn't have happened I'll just say that this if it should go down we would never have to go through this oh my god I have so many tabs open dedicated to this so many tabs open dedicated to the sea lad all
right let's see Where is it?
Okay, it has to be...
Where's my...
Okay, my confirmed order.
History.
Oh my god.
My history is just all sea land.
Right.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All for the bit.
I mean, all hail or grace and touch is the sea land.
May your days be filled of content and success.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you
All right Would it be better if I look at this on light mode?
Okay, where's light mode on outlook?
Where is light mode It's fine.
We'll just do where is light mode for outlook?
Oh, look I'm gonna tweet this out.
It should be Because it's like all...
You can barely see it, guys!
You can barely see it!
Alright.
It's fine.
Okay, I'll just use...
Fine.
I'll use...
I'll use what I have.
Is it window settings?
For my outlook?
I use outlook.
How...
How to change outlook setting...
light mode settings okay go to the view tab select light reading to change the message okay go to the view tab what the fuck is the view tab oh there it is oh I found it oh there it light there we go now we can see okay now okay here we go alright
I I found it.
Don't worry, I found it, guys.
I need to Photoshop something.
Alright, what should my tweet be?
Needs to be a banger caption.
Alright, this is light mode, but...
Okay, wait, actually...
Let me know.
Light mode or dark mode?
Or light or night...
Light or night mode?
That's like dite mode.
Alright.
Here you go.
Here's the options.
This is night mode.
Don't worry.
It'll be uncensored.
Here it is.
Light mode.
Light mode is more awful.
Okay, we'll do night mode then.
but but all right all right all right guys when you have bang your caption for this
just this one time light mode is more formal that is true the night light mode is more formal
all right
Cheers for...
Um, we like paper here, okay?
We are a paper community.
This better be...
Alright.
The Dutch...
The...
Duchess Doki Bird and Sir Dad.
of sea land.
Officially.
I am.
I am officially.
Wait.
Please kneel before.
And sir.
Doki Amber.
Okay.
Doki Amber Doge.
Of sea land.
Oh, kneel before Duchess Doki Bird and Sir Doki.
Okay, wait.
Officially, Duchess, okay, kneel before.
There
we go.
Okay, kneel, kneel before.
Oh my god, do you think that's a little too aggressive, guys?
Or should I just be like, Duchess Dorkybird and Sir Dorky...
Or should I just be like, Duchess Dorkybird and Sir Dorky Aphrodite of Celeste?
I'll just do that.
Or be like, I can't buy my credit card.
Oh wait, oh wait, wait.
My credit card declined my purchase for an automatic feeder for my dog, but yet lets me buy a royal title.
Nobility.
Nobility title.
So now I'm the Duchess of...
Now I'm the Duchess of Sealand.
There you go.
You're not just...
What a big and light novel title.
I'm the Duchess of Sela now.
I did it, guys.
Alright, what...
Alright.
here i wanted if i wanted to buy games and play games and buy it all i feel like but became a duchess instead don't you hate that when when you're crying won't let you buy a basic necessity so you just decide to become a duchess
it's such a fever i'm very disappointed in it
hey guys look in the end this is itchio's fault if itchio was not down we would be playing games right now all right guys i'm gonna call it here i had a great time hanging out with all of you don't worry i will show i will show it on stream chat do not worry i will make sure to show it on stream but thank you all for coming to today's stream i don't think we expected it to go the way it went today but i hope you guys all had a great time as a whole or or are are disappointed in me like could be either it could be both too it could be both hey guys as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around to get the blood flowing and you stay up for me head to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye all right
since i'm a dutch in there um the duchess of sealand is officially signing off goodbye